hey what is up guys angka Bhd here and
welcome to the always sunny Hawthorne
California there's plenty of cool stuff
here there's a Hyperloop test track form
two yards away from me there's
superchargers but we're here at the
Tesla design studio where you often see
some of their latest and greatest stuff
what we're here for is to look at their
latest and greatest car Tesla Model 3 so
shout out to Tesla for this car for this
week for this video shows they actually
really care about you guys and this is
only my second time ever in a Model 3 as
rare as this car is it makes sense but
we should we should probably name this
thing
[Music]
you try so for a little context model 3
is important because of what it
represents which is essentially the
final step in the master plan that Tesla
outlined a couple of years ago what they
wanted to do was create number one a
very expensive
very low volume electric car which they
did then use that money to create a
slightly more high volume slightly less
expensive car that they did and then use
that money to create a mass market
affordable electric car that's this so
the number they landed at was starting
at $35,000 but as you probably know with
a lot of cars that say starting at a
certain price almost none of those cars
cost that actual price you get some
options you kind of spec it up to look
the way you want it to and then you have
that final price same thing with model 3
so almost no model 3 is on the road are
actually going to cost thirty five
thousand dollars despite this being the
$35,000 Tesla in fact this one that
we're driving this week thanks to Tesla
has quite a few upgrades and ends up at
fifty seven thousand dollars so the
options on this car to get to that price
are obviously the base price of $35,000
long range battery upgrade so that's
$9,000 the premium upgrades package
$5,000 the red multi coat paint which is
pretty sweet
that's a thousand bucks the 19-inch
wheels over the 18 inch that are
standard that's 1500 and then enhanced
autopilot which is five thousand dollars
and then there's a destination fee of a
thousand bucks and that's how you get to
your fifty seven thousand dollar price
so that's creeping up into Model S
territory not quite obviously the base
price is lower but now you find yourself
not really comparing this to other
$30,000 cars but comparing it to other
50 $60,000 cars that's just me I'm gonna
shamelessly compare it to the one car I
know best which is my Tesla Model S and
just embrace it but that's how I'm gonna
figure out if those options are worth it
and if Model 3 turns out to be worth the
price so let's get started
[Music]
so right off the bat something a lot of
people have talked about in model 3
versus model s is air suspension versus
this coil suspension Model S that bigger
slightly older but slightly better car
has air suspension which is very very
smooth and adjustable and this coil
suspension is not adjustable so you
can't change the height of the car so it
rides at a certain height always and
it'll always be a certain firmness just
depending on how firm those coils are
going over smaller bumps or potholes or
even turning you can feel it like it's
it's a little more pronounced and it's
sharper so air suspension smooth things
out a lot more some people prefer air
suspension I'm one of those people some
people actually prefer coil suspension
when they feel like they like that
firmer grip but yeah this is this is
definitely a bit different from model s
all right let's give a low scale auto
park a shot probably don't need help
parking a spot this big but not a lot of
40 50 thousand dollar cars have Auto
Park so you pull up in front to the car
next to you when you throw it in reverse
you get a button that says start press
start the string will starts moving car
starts moving in Reverse by itself and
you can look at the rearview mirror if
you want but it's gonna do everything
from this point on without your input
this is for those of you who have a fear
of parallel parking one thing you do
have to get used to though but it didn't
take me that long is looking to the
right for the speed and although
generally the stuff that's usually
behind the steering wheel
there's no tech commoner obviously
because there's no gears but you still
kind of want to know if you're in Drive
or neutral you want to know your speed
you want to know your battery and while
you're driving you don't want to look
that far off the road but I've actually
trained my glance now to go just over to
the top corner of this screen instead of
behind the wheel it's still just so
quiet like when I turn the AC down here
no noise no engine noise I mean it's
electric makes perfect sense but still
something I'll get used to sometimes you
you start to hear every little anything
that rattles anything that creaks you'll
hear that instead highway driving like
this gives the opportunity just to look
around the inside of the car and I'm
gonna echo a lot of things I've like
read about this car but you don't really
feel that until you're in it visibility
with the glass everywhere is awesome
rear visibility of the glass is huge the
other glass above you and the front
glass and the hood slopes down so much
that you can you can see right over the
front and nose of the car and you feel
like you see just a road right in front
so now we'd made our way up to the edge
of the canyons now it was time for some
slightly more fun and more uphill Canyon
driving all right let's talk efficiency
so model three is obviously a lighter
car than Model S so it's gonna have
better efficiency slightly better so the
past six miles we've been driving uphill
to get into these canyons and the watt
hour per mile rating that's a relative
measure of efficiency for these cars is
pretty high it's up over 700 but we're
about to turn around and go back down
those same six miles and you'll see the
rating is of course much lower because
that's what happens when you go downhill
an electric car regenerative braking
let's do it
[Music]
so doing all this driving in these windy
twisty turny roads up and down the
canyons like this you really feel things
like the smaller size of this car it's
not a compact by any means but it has a
smaller steering wheel and the steering
ratio is actually tighter so that the
whole car feels tighter and more agile
and handling so it actually handles
better but overall yeah the driving
reminded me still a lot of my car not as
fast obviously but still zippy and
smooth and the linear acceleration
instead of gear shifting is still pretty
unique I kind of love it all right just
like I was saying the power of
regenerative braking we started at the
top of this mountain six miles ago with
233 miles on this car's battery but can
should get our efficiency on the way
down we've used an average of negative
163 watt hours per mile which puts us at
actually adding to the battery in our
past six miles so now at the top we have
238 miles left on the battery
all right now we're headed out of the
mountains leaving now and we're gonna
head over to the TLD studio which is
about 45 minutes I'll show you exactly
how many miles that is but we have
plenty of range to go so I'm gonna go
ahead and ring the car to them let them
see it for a little bit check it out
they don't like
so on our way to John Studios still and
this gives me a chance to demonstrate
since there's a lot of cars on the road
one of I think the most underrated
features of any Tesla which is autopilot
in stop-and-go traffic that's actually
the time that I use it the most so what
I do is double tap the stock down which
is a little different I kind of missed
that dedicated autopilot stock but now I
can just not focus on driving I don't
have to worry about stopping if the guy
in front of me stops my car will stop
the guy in front of me goes my car will
go it's that simple
if there's one thing I learned model 3
has over model s it's that it's more of
a unicorn especially out here in
California where there are Tesla's and
Tesla enthusiasts everywhere this car is
is still actually turning heads it's
super rare anyway I figured it would
also be useful to get some more candid
opinions of some youtubers including one
future Tesla Model 3 owner and current
reservation holder I normally don't like
red but I like it on this one I cause
multi Co red it's different from like
the darker founders red which looks kind
of brown yeah right way distant gasp oh
wait wait so yeah general consensus was
no matter how you feel about electric
cars yeah this thing is pretty cool just
as cool as any other Tesla so now as
someone who has driven and experienced
this Model 3 for a little while what are
my thoughts on it on the whole
experience what you get for the money
and are all the upgrade options worth it
well at a base price of 35,000 I think
it's pretty clear it's the best electric
car in the price range right now but
that's with no options but the options
are worth considering the long range
option is nine thousand dollars but that
brings you from a base 220 mile range to
310 miles so basically nine thousand
bucks for ninety more miles but that's
basically plus 50 percent range and for
a lot of people that's actually gonna be
worth it people with longer commutes and
longer daily driving the premium
interior also goes a long way for five
thousand bucks
you go from a metal roof to the glass
roof you get a much improved speaker
system that for me qualifies as the
loudest I've ever heard in a car heated
seats power moving seats the wood trim
in the front and the leather seats just
it seems like a no-brainer to me so go
for that the red paint you can totally
skip and save your thousand bucks there
but it is beautiful then again I am
biased and then the 19-inch wheels that
are slightly heavier and slightly less
efficient you can also skip these no
problem and get the baseline 18-inch
keep in mind though if you're after
performing
might be best to wait all around for an
all-wheel-drive version of model 3 to be
announced and an autopilot for 5000
bucks I don't really see how you can get
a Tesla and not get autopilot but if you
do decide to go that way and then regret
it later
you can pay a little more to enable it
with a software update because every
Tesla out the factory has all the
cameras and all the sensors to make it
happen
but bottom line I think this is a good
looking good driving electric car and
for the price it does some things even
better than Model S right now like the
futuristic air-conditioner event that's
controlled on the touchscreen that can
redirect airflow at your face or around
your head pretty awesome the bigger area
of glass around the back and the top of
this car gives you more Headroom or just
like the little things like the way the
front trunk opens and closes easier or
the touchscreen UI is a little bit
cleaner and a little bit faster a lot of
the stuff I'd expect to see in a Model S
refresh pretty soon but it's obviously
all still great to see in this cheaper
car too so it's pretty clear I'm a fan
of the Model 3 I was before I came out
here to drive it and I still am now now
that I have so that's been episode one
of autofocus if you enjoyed it
definitely hit that like button and let
me know what car should I check out next
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace